hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
uncovering the membrane mechanism
of cytokinesis using live cell imaging
and subcellular
optogenetic tools i'm christy jewell of
labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored
by andor for more information on our
sponsor please visit
andor.com
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top of your
presentation window
or report your problem by using the ask
a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd now like to introduce our speakers
dr alan mullen
product specialist for microscopy
cameras at andor
dr jean castillo postdoctoral research
associate
washington university school of medicine
in st louis
and dr claudia florindo product
specialist
life sciences andor for complete
biographies honor speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr castillo you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody thank you for the
introduction my name is jian castillo
i will show the data from my work the
title is
uncovering the membrane mechanisms of
cytokinesis
using live cell imaging and subcellular
optogenetic tools
our lab uses optogenetic methods to
spatially confine
critical and molecular control in
selective regions of a single cell
dynamic networks of interacting
signaling proteins
govern cellular behavior in processes
like cell migration
differentiation secretion
and contraction all those processes are
controlled
by signaling proteins that transitions
the signal
through the cell the ability
to selectively control the activity of
a specific signaling components in a
network
can be valuable in gaining a better
understanding
of the network dynamics that executes
cell behavior the most common use
methods to study cell signaling are
genetic methods like knockout knockdowns
or
the use of mutants and pharmacological
methods like the use of
any inhibitors activators agonies or
antagonists
but they have a limital control over
location
or time optogenetics
gives us precise control over location
and the time that we want maintain the
signal
also this technique let us let us see
changes in real time
and like we mentioned we have the
control of the
signal localization then we can change
the region or interest
exit different optogenetic tools where
you can optically
activate membrane proteins like
receptors
and some g protein-coupled receptors
like opsins
or there are some constructs that let
you activate
receptor tyrosine kinases rtk's
receptors that
let us activate the whole pathway
the whole the whole signaling pathway
like when we use
uh an agonist there is
a another other optogenetic
tools are like sensitive and show
conformational change
in response to light and some of this
tool
let us induce protein dynamization
with this we can have optical control of
the protein localization recruiting
proteins to different regions of the
cell
and these control glados activate or
deactivate
a specific domestic proteins in the
pathway
in red we have the activated proteins
and in blue light we have the activated
proteins
the spectrox selectivity of optogenetic
tools
allow us to image simultaneously
fluorescent proteins or fluorophores
while we are casting cell behavior
using this approach we deconstruct
complex cell behavior to understand the
mechanisms
at their basis i mean our optogenetic
tools respond
or is sensitive to blue light
this let us us image another fluorescent
proteins like
yellow proteins or red proteins at the
same time
this is the microscope configuration
that we have in in the lab
where we have the messiah and the mirror
arrangement
that let us perform localized photo
activation in a specific regional
interest selected in the software and
also
we have the we have a dragonfly with
uh that and where is the spinning and
the spinning disc
and the tear and sword
in our love patrick o'neill developed an
optogenetic tool
that is based on light induced
dimerization
this tool let us achieve subcellular
control over the activation
of endogenous row a in a specific size
of the cell
we optically trigger membrane
recruitment
of a raw selective one in and nucleotide
exchange factor
dev for roy
the interaction between a protein sspv
and its peptide binding target ssra
is rendering light dependent by fusing
ssra to the blue light sensitive
lov domain the lov domain is attached to
the membrane by a
cox motif and
these in the dark state
state is fold hiding necessary
then when we shine light
the eyelid unfolds and lets the
interaction between
ss sspv and ssra
then we recruit the gaf to the membrane
that activates roy
i will show you some examples where we
used this optogenetic tool
and also you can see one of the
advantages that i mentioned before
we can change the signal localization
and induce a different cell behavior
we work with macrophages a cell line
grow cells
264 and 7
and we perform all the experiments in
these cells
also like i mentioned before we use a
gaf and this gap is called
large specific for row a
and also it's known that roy mediates
cell retraction
in the first movie you will see an
example of cell migration induced by
roy photo activation in green
you will see the member marking and also
you will see
a white rectangle or box
that represent the region where we shine
light
you will see this box in all my movies
and we can see how the cell
moves in opposite direction to the light
exactly on immediately when i start to
shine light
in the second movie we have the member
marker in green
and we are using a
[Music]
nuclear marker in red and we can see
like when i i change and i
photo activate row a in the middle the
cell
contract and form a cleavage photo
the third movie if i don't shine light
the cell does nothing
once that we found that we are able uh
to induce for formation by
optically optical activation of roy
we decided to study the membrane
mechanisms involved in
this process that is part of cytokinesis
which is an important part of cell
division
then cytokinesis takes place
at the end of anaphase and is the
process to separate one cell in two
the process implies a cleavage furrow
then an intracellular bridge
and the last step is the pinch of
a final coat at the sum of the free of
the bridge
we think of in this process there is a
membrane remodeling
but how does membrane remodeling occur
to form
the cytokinetic phoro and
to create the intracellular bridge
then our hypothesis is that especially
localized endocytosis and exocytosis
play
a role in this remodeling that is
necessary for
cytokinesis this is based on the
involvement of
trafficking protein like graph 11
and r6 in photo formation
as we know vesicular trafficking is the
transport of the cell
products between subcellular components
like the endoplasmic reticulum and golgi
via vesicles to and from the plasma
membrane
and another a specific cell location
there are two process endocytosis
that is the internalization
of proteins and membrane from the plasma
membrane to the cytosol
and exocytosis the exportation
of proteins and membrane from the
cytosol to the plasma membrane
first of all of we evaluate
in our system if the for reformation was
because the royal
activity in was induced by or
optogenetic construct
to check that we use a
roy activity sensor rgbd the rotekin
gvd which binds to roy gtp
i mean activated row a form
then we can look for activator row a
localization in the movie the red
channel
is our optogenetic construct the green
channel is our
roy activity sensor rgbd
and you will see like after for
information
the rgbd is localized in the full
region this means that the forward
formation is because
we photo activate grey and
this is not a spontaneous
event also here
we introduce a second box
to form an intracellular bridge and also
i will tell you that
we called this for my future movies
and we call this region the back of the
daughter cell
and the front of the cell back
front
we know from a previous work in our lab
that the activation of roe
induced active myosin contractility that
result
in membrane flow then
we check if there is membrane flow
during for
formation for this experiment we attach
bits to the membrane
the bits are color red and the member
marker is
green and like you will see in the first
movie
after induce 4 of formation
we see how the the membranes start to
flow the cell
contract and the beads flow
to them to the middle to the forward
region
also in the green channel we can see
membrane accumulation in the full region
because the membrane flow
in the second movie we form an
intracellular
bridge after fall formation
and you will see
we found that the beads don't flow
through the bridge they
stay in the back of the door cell
that means that the bridge is
forming for
by newman by addition
of new membrane not because mem
flow
like we suppose there is membrane
incorporation
by vesicular trafficking and also
it is known that low membrane tension
induces endocytosis next we use
a low membrane tension marker the
forming binding protein 17
fvp17 and like you will see
in the movie the red channel is the
memory marker
in green we have fpp 17
which binds to the membrane with low
tension
and after for formation
we see how the low tension marker
is localized in the full region
in the back of the daughter cell
also in the red channel you can see some
membrane accumulation because
the membrane flow and also
these uh results
tell us that there is low tension in the
back of the dart cells
and endocytosis could be there
the next was drag endocytic vesicles and
their
localization during photo formation to
do this we use
a fluorescent ligand transferring alexa
594
in red and after five minutes of
incubation
the transfer in alexa internalized with
the transparent receptor
via cluttering mediated endocytosis
but you will see in the first movie
after induced forward formation
the vesicles containing transferring
alexa
in red
localized in the photo
and in the back of the cell
the green is the membrane marker
in the second movie we use another
endocytic marker cavalin which is a
membrane protein one of the
principal components of cavalier
membranes
and is involved in receptor independent
endocytosis i mean in a deep
it's a different
endocytosis mechanism independent of
clattering
and in red is cavulin
the second movie and the green is the
member marker
and like you will see
gavilan localized in full
region and if we keep
photo activating it seems that is inside
the
intercellular bridge
that means that endocytosis is taking
place but all
in in all this region
and in this process if we look for
another
endos endocytic proteins or we look for
recycling endosome proteins and
in this case we drag
graph 11 like
we know the rough proteins play an
essential role in
the process that underlie the targeting
and fuse
confusion of transport vesicles with
their appropriate
acceptor membranes then they are in
charge of the sorting in
in endosomes in the first movie
grav 11 is in red the member marker is
in green
and like you you will see after
photo formation
the rav 11 localized
in the back of the dollar cell the
second movie
when we know when we knock down
grab 11 by using a dominant negative
protein
in the the green channel the red channel
in this case is our member marker
you will see that the cell can contract
but it cannot
form a photo
this means that the recycling endosome
is important for for uh formation
that vesicular trafficking is a pro a
important process during photo formation
and if we he leave it
uh a part of that and the forward
and the cell cannot form the form
we look for exocytic proteins and
rf6 is a protein that is involved in
exocytosis and endocytosis
and in the first movie you will see
in the red channel the membrane marker
the green channel we have
r6 and after induced form formation
we can see how rf6 localized
in the forward region and also after
some minutes it localized in the
intercellular bridge
in the second movie
when we knock down rf6 by
using a dominant negative in
the greek channel the red channel is
remember marker
you will see like the cell contracts
but it cannot induce a photo
it cannot form a photo
and in the third movie we use a
constitutive active r6 which
was fused to the cn fluorescent protein
that
we didn't image
because technical
problems because if we can induce global
photo activation
for optogenetic construct if we
image blue proteins
then in the third movie like you will
see the red channel
is or optogenetic construct the green
channel is a member margin
and you will see that when we express r6
constitutive active the cell
also cannot form the photo
this means that the cell
don't just need the rf6 activity
also it needs the
dynamic switch on and off of rf6
during photo formation
another exocitic marker that we used was
exo70 which is part of the exorcist
complex and it is it is involved
in the last step of exocytosis before
membrane fusion
in the first movie like you will see in
the red channel we have a member marker
in the green channel we have
x70
and after for information
you will see like x17
is localized in the forum and
appears in the intercellular breach
this makes sense because is report
that exo70 interacts with rf6
in exocytic process
then we think that there is a exocytosis
in this region of the cell
to probably form the form of the
bridge and also it makes sense because
all the machinery is
recruited but it's localized there
in the second movie and also i will show
how we can combine
uh the optical control and
use inhibitors small molecules
um and see the effect in real time
then we use a anime on inhibitor
for exo70 endocytin 2
and we'll see like after incubation
we found that the cell can contract
but can not induce
or produce the fault the for the climate
for
then that means that exocytosis is
required
for in the for information
here i will present one of the most
interesting results
that i have or one of the experiments
that i like
the most and also this shows
another advantage of the the system
configuration that we have we can induce
two different process at the same
time endocytosis and cytokinesis and
then watch the effect with time
and local control here i use the same
fluorescent ligand
transferring alexa 594 and
to see more precise where endocytosis
was taking place and what happens when
we activate endocytosis
while we induce for formation
then the idea is to add the transferring
industry and the transferring
then induce
endocytosis of the transferring receptor
by the sensitization
and see what what happened and like you
will see in the movie
in the red channel is the transparent
we're going to challenge the member
marker once that i
form the photo i add the transferring
and like you will see
in the same time that you start to see
endocytic vesicles
the intercellular bridge start to
elongate
and you can see some vesicles
inside the intercellular bridge then
enhancing endocytosis
increases the bridge length
then we ask what happens if we enhance
the exocytosis to do this we over
express cytohesing 2
a one in nucleotide exchange factor
for r6 in the movie the red channel is
or optogenetic
construct the green channel is
cytohesing 2
and we found that the over
expression of cytohesing 2 is enough
to increase the bridge length
we found also that with this condition
we can in a form long bridges
this bridge is a little bit wider
compared with the
bridge when we enhance endocytosis
then enhancing exocytosis increases
the bridge length and
vesicular trafficking is required for
the bridge formation
looking for how similar was or
optogenetic model
we look for some structural proteins
that play a role in cytokinesis and also
in the intercellular bridge formation
and
we decide to uh to look for septins
septins are cytoskeletal proteins that
form
drink structures and are involved this
this proteins are involved in
cytokinesis and
they they are involved in the
intercellular bridge formation
like you will see in the movie the red
channel is our member marker
the green channel is septem7
and you will see also this is one of
my longest videos
and you will see that when we express
this
septic 7
we form long also we
induce long bridges you can increase the
length
the bridge length
and also we keep photo activating
like you will see
if we keep default activating we found
that these cells
form an structure similar to the
mid body
like i mentioned before septim septins
form
a ring structure and also involving the
meatball deformation
and you will see like
after a while hey see that in the middle
of the
intercellular bridge you start to appear
this
structural the structure similar
to the mid body
then we think that septins localize in
the intercellular bridge
to to configure or give this
tubular a
structure and form the midbody
you will see here this
structure
we think that the forward elongation to
form the intracellular bridge
is mediated by membrane incorporation
through exocytosis and to see where
exocitosis
is first we combine confocal microscopy
optical control and fluorescence
recovery after photobleaching frap
and you will see in the first movie in
the red channel kabulin
the green channel is the member market
and i've
photobleached in the middle of the cell
and immediately i
start to photoactivate to induce for
formation you will see
that the fluorescence is recovered
by membrane flow mostly but you will see
you can see some vesicles going there
in the second movie we induce uh
like we know that we we are able to
induce long bridges or
long intracellular breaches by
overexpressing
cytocasting two we use these
and also we use a membrane marker gpi
to see internal vesicles
after induce for affirmation and form
a bridge you will see a
photobleach in the middle of the
intercellular bridge
you will see the box
there and you will see how some vesicles
move inside the bridge
there is another photo a photobleaching
cycle
and you see how the
fluorescence in the membrane is
recovered
and it seems that some vesicles fuse
with the membrane then this means that
there is exocytosis
in the intercellular bridge
next we use total internal reflection
fluorescence
turf which is ideal for visualizing
events
such as exocytosis which occurs
at or near the plasma membrane around
100 nanometers above the substrate
and we combine tier and optical control
to see more clear exocytosis and
we use a like a bump to
a protein involved in membrane fusion
2 is used to ph sensitive protein
which is less bright in endosomes
in acid phs and
it is brighter when is in the membrane
ph 7 and you will see
in the movie in the
left channel
the black line represents the outline
of the cell and you will see bump two
and after for formation we can see how
some dark spots appear
in the front of the cell
you see here
then we can see that bump is polarized
in the front
and this results show that there is
exocytosis at the front of the cell
also a bump stay in the membrane
for a while the kinetics of pump
is around 20 minutes before come back in
endosomes
to see independent exocytosis event
we use again turf combined with optical
control
of the photo formation and in this
experiment we use
the neuropeptide y which has been used
like a secretion marker the
mpy is also fused
to a ph sensitive protein
ph tomato which is less bright in
endosome
acid phs and it
is brighter when it is in the membrane
ph 7
also mp mpy is secreted
to the extracellular media and diffuse
then you will see in the movie the left
channel
and the outline represent the
the cell
and after in this four formation we
found how
some dark spots appear and disappear
in the front of the cell there like you
can see
then we this is another result that
tell us that there is exocytosis
at the front of the cell
if to see if the cell is using
exocytosis to incorporate new membrane
and to see from where this membrane
comes
we perform the next experiment we use a
fluorophore
to stain the membrane fm464
which is red also it can be washable
from the plasma membrane then if we look
the scheme
i incubate the cell with fm464
and after 30 minutes it gets
internalized
and it stains internal vesicles
then i washed it from the the membrane
keeping just the vesicles containing
fm 464 if the new incorporated membrane
comes from endosomes then the plasma
membrane will stain again
for this experiment i combined
surface stream turf imaging
and optogenetic in the movie like you
will see the first channel is sm464
in green is we have cluttering which we
use
like a control just to check that the
cell is not just getting close to the
surface
and like you will see in the beginning
the vesicles
are in the middle
after induced forward formation we can
see
some vesicles moving to the front and
after some minutes a line of fm
464 fluorescence appear
at the front edge of the cell indicating
that
vesicles are incorporated into the
plasma membrane
also you will see some here like some
arrows
that show this and
this is in contrast to cluttering which
uh appear in vesicles but
didn't form a
note line at the front edge then
also we could see just this membrane
incorporation
by use by using surface stream
image you can see here
then we propose a model where roy
activation in the middle of the cell
causes ingression and cleavage for
reformation
due to the active active myosin
contraction
and plasma membrane flow to the site of
ray activation this leads
to decreased membrane tension in the
furrow
and increase endocytosis
as the intracellular intercellular
bridge forms
endocytosis is localized
to the backs of the nas and daughter
cells
the entos endos endocytose vesicles
undergo exoc to exocytosis into this
this distinct regions using two
different mechanisms
in the first mechanisms the vesicles are
trafficking to recycle an endosome
containing
graph 11 and then to the
intracellular breach where they undergo
rf6 and exo70 mediated
exocytosis this supplies
membrane lipids needed to the for the
bridge formation
in the second mechanism the vesicles
undergo
exocytosis at the front of the daughter
cells
mediated by snare proteins like
bam ii this mechanism
serves to replace the plasma membrane
lipids
at the front edge allowing the dollar
cells to maintain their shape
as they move apart and elongate the
bridge
then as we see subcellular optogenetics
provides experimental control over
complex cell behavior
so that the mechanisms can be addressed
here we use this approach to show that
localized trafficking control
cytokinesis and also this technique
can be used similar to unders to
understand the basis of other cell
behaviors
and it can also be used in the future
for therapeutic
properties
thank you so much uh thanks to my love
and especially senior mischief and
anupandi that helped me a lot in
this work thank you
in this part of the presentation we're
going to look at surfstream
which is a self-friendly flexible and
accessible
super resolution method so
we're going to look first of all what
surf is and how it compares with a
number of other super resolution
methodologies and then also
looking then about what is surfstream
and how this differs from normal surf
and then how you actually can use
surfstream for live cell imaging
purposes
so as we know um server resolution
techniques are used to see
beyond the diffraction limit and
conventional light microscopy
methods of course are limited by
diffraction
and that works out to be around
200 to 300 nanometers and below that
range
um you know the inner workings of the
cell are essentially lost in that haze
but we can consider
information beyond the diffraction limit
in terms of the point spread function
and
of course now we have a wide range of
super resolution techniques that allow
us to view subcellular structures and
processes in detail
i'm not going to these in the workings
of these in any detail
but obviously we have a range of them
from storm
palm stead and also some as well
and each of these will have their own
strengths and disadvantages
so some of the limitations include
having to use specialized equipment such
as high power lasers or particular
optical setups
also we may need to use special
photo switching fluorophores and so
so-called blinking fluorophores but the
other one that
of most concern to us for life cell
imaging really
is in terms of illumination so
illumination intensity is particularly
important for live cell imaging
we can see that from a technique like
wide field
we might be in order of milliwatts per
centimeter squared
um sem moving up into watts per
centimeter squared and then into palm
and storm
where you are dealing with um into the
kilowatts per centimeter squared which
is really quite a high level
of light this brings us to
surf where together it's full title
super resolution radio fluctuations
and this was originally developed by
ricardo henriquez and his colleagues
back in 2016 so it's been around for a
few
three few years now and what this does
is it provides a self-friendly flexible
and accessible super resolution
by cell friendly we mean that this is an
approach
which is analytical based and requires
orders of magnitude less light than the
existing methods that we've just
mentioned
and it's flexible and accessible to all
so it's purely a software-based super
resolution
approach there's no need for any
specialized equipment
and also it is able to use any
fluorophores so
standards gfp or other common
fluorophores allow us to have
flexibility over
the labeling that we're going to use it
can also use any imaging modality
so that can be wide field turf or
confocal
and there's the post processing version
of surf
is a free and open source mhj plugin
so how does surf work
well what we do with surf is we capture
a burst of
image frames of very short exposure with
the view to trying to localize the
emission
from the from a point source of the
fluorophore
and then we upscale the pixels of the
camera
into virtual virtual pixels essentially
so this allows us to localize the
emission
more accurately
and then using a gpu we're able to
compute the local intensity gradients
from each of these pixels and then we
can interpolate
the gradients then in this virtual array
of sub pixels
and that allows us to quite precisely
and accurately
work out where the original
source of the illumination is
and key to this is having the gpu
and of course gpus are well known for
other techniques now
such as for deconvolution
and by using the power of this
shear processing of the gpus we're able
to do this
very very quickly
and so we're taking 100 frames very
short exposure say 10 milliseconds
and then we're trying to work out where
the location
of the emission is from
and then we can rebuild the image from
that and then we have this super
resolved image
so we've just mentioned what surf is so
what then is the difference between
normal surf and surf stream
well surf stream is a development of
surf which is exclusive to andor
technology
and this came about because of the
collaboration with ricardo henriquez
and that andor had a lot of experience
of gpu optimization for deconvolution
so what we did then is that we were able
to
optimize the gpu operations
and greatly enhance the speed of surf
and what that allows is for actually
real-time integration of the acquisition
events
and the surf analysis and that provides
real-time super resolution
so it is not just the normal
post-processing of the normal surf
so how can you use surfstream for live
cell imaging applications
well one option as we're going to hear
about later is to do with the
using it with the dragonfly confocal
system
then another option is basically
any microscope you just need to have an
outdoor exxon emccd camera which
provides a sensitivity required to
operate
at these very short exposures then a
surf license
that is locked to the camera and then of
course the gpu enabled pc
so what resolution and space are
possible from surfstream
resolution wise typically two to six
times better than the original data is
possible
so that's using high na objective
and ensuring that the image itself is
properly sampled according to nyquist
criteria
so that means that 50 to 150 nanometers
of lateral resolution is possible
depending on the sample and the
fluorophore density
so a low density of fluorophore will
tend towards giving a higher resolution
likewise taking more samples
will provide improved resolution as well
at the expense of lower speed
and speed wise with a normal
configuration of taking 100 frames each
with
10 milliseconds exposure that is
equating to
around one frame per second but of
course we can start to look at
regions of interest and as well as using
a slightly smaller number of input
frames
and then that way that we can start to
boost speeds up higher
between 2.5 5 and over 10
frames per second
so in summary surfstream is an under
exclusive version of surf
that exploits optimized gpu processing
it shares many of the key benefits of
surf and adds in a real-time dimension
to this
so that provides a real-time lifestyle
super resolution solution
from a camera with a standard microscope
setup
or alternatively via the android
dragonfly confocal system
so it will run in micromanager in a
camera based setup
or within the dragonfly via fusion
and surfstream is highly applicable to
analysis of sub-cellular organelles
tracking and membrane studies as we've
just heard primarily because
of this the low illumination
and the high speed lifestyle aspects of
it
coupled with the conventional
fluorophore side of things
so now we are going to go on to hear
more about
the android dragonfly
thank you dr castillo and dr mullen
and thank you christy for handing over
to me now
i will wrap up showing andor solutions
for imaging and photo manipulation
so i just would like to give a first
start of the imaging challenges that dr
castillo faced when was
designing his experiments so he
performed as you've seen
a lot of live imaging and one
when a researcher does a lot of live
imaging
there are challenges that are very
obvious when performing live imaging
such as photo toxicity and photo
bleaching
and also in the case of dr castillo
speed was a very important requirement
the high
temporal resolution that he needed to
induce photonomic
manipulation and acquire the images
you have also seen dr castillo
delivering
multiple imaging techniques such as
confocal
turf surf and frap
he also performed super resolution and
there are several challenges
when facing live cell super resolution
he used optogenetic tools to induce the
cleavage furrow
and then he needed an imaging system
that would acquire with high temporal
resolution the induced furrow
so i will now point out and our
solutions
to address these imaging challenges
endor has the dragonfly multipoint
spinning disc based on the micro lens
spinning disc
technology dragonfly is a multi-modal
platform
it is an instant multi-point confocal
that also delivers laser white field
imaging
turf super resolution modalities this
storm and surf
with a very broad range of excitation
wavelengths from the visible to the near
infrared and a very flat you
illumination
across the whole field of view the
borealis patent
and or illumination system
you can see the comparison between the
dragonfly and the single point scanning
system
where the images in a multi-point
confocal are delivered
much faster than in a single point
scanning confocal
and with faster acquisition you increase
the temporal
resolution of your images because we
have a dual
spinning risk length system there's
higher efficiency in the capture of
light and therefore it's less
toxic and this combined with endor's
high sensitive detectors just presented
by
allen deliver the capture
of more photons of an image
and it's less phototoxic and less
photobleaching
and you can capture even the deepest
signals
in a cell these specifications of the
dragonfly
include acquisition speeds up to 400
frames per second
in the confocal mode a very large field
of view
to match the 5.5 megapixels xyla camera
within a 16 bit dynamic range of
acquisition
a broad range of excitation wavelengths
from the 405 till the near infrared
wavelengths
785 nanometers and the highly uniformity
across a broad range of wavelengths and
across the whole
field of view and due to all of these
characteristics it's not surprising that
the dragonfly has a broad range of
applications
for life sciences such as live
and fixed cell imaging membrane dynamics
example exocytosis developmental biology
cancer research organoids neuroscience
and single molecule localization imaging
i now propose you to analyze the live
cell super resolution challenge
techniques that are compatible with live
cell imaging
are wide field and confocal imaging
multi-point spinning disk confocal but
when you want to break the diffraction
limit of light many of the techniques
available
are not compatible with life cell
imaging
moving into the red and red areas
being less and less compatible with
lifestyle imaging
and this is due to high laser power
requirements also to the
acquisition timings that can be from
minutes
to hours and therefore you have a
problem
in the delivering the temporal
resolution needed
for lifestyle imaging in many
experiments and also
very complex probe preparation in 2016
professor ricardo and hicks have
developed
a super resolution technique that is
compatible with lifestyle imaging
that is named serf professor fricarduin
hiker further collaborated with ender
to develop a gpu-based algorithm
embedded
into our cameras and into andor
dragonfly software which is fusion
surfstream yields an increase in
resolution
between two to six times more
than conventional no diffraction limited
data giving resolutions from
50 to 150 nanometer final
resolution the low power requirements
that are needed to deliver a surf stream
image
make it compatible with live cell image
surfstream algorithm and or search
stream algorithm
allows acquisition of images that break
the diffraction limit of light
as fast as 10 frames per second
and importantly surfstream can be images
cannot
be acquired deep inside cells or tissues
another characteristics that i would
like to show you of the dragonfly
is that due to the borealis uniform
elimination
and with the stitching algorithm
embedded into fusion
you can acquire large organisms
and stitch it with seamless stitching
having
very detailed resolution at very high
magnifications but at the same time
being able to visualize
all the organism that you wanted to
acquire
so dragonfly is offered in two models
the dragonfly 500 a complex a complete
solution with all the imaging modalities
that the dragonfly has to offer
and the dragonfly 200 a more compact
solution
with that is offered in the upright and
inverted systems
and i'm now going to talk about the
photomanipulation tools
that endor has to offer andor offers
the micropoint and mosaic as the
photomanipulation
devices mosaic delivers enter
patent dmd technology it is composed
of half a million individual mirrors
those mirrors are controlled
individually
through the software and this delivers a
very precise control
over light in both space and time
being able to illuminate different
regions simultaneously
and this illumination devices and
controlling the different mirrors
simultaneously allows the illumination
of different regions
of a cellular structure at the same time
in this movie presented you can see
multiple regions being illuminated
simultaneously
with the mosaic
micropoint provides a flexible and field
proven tool
for photo stimulation it is delivered
with endor
patented compact pulse laser
nitrogen pumped tunable dye laser
and it's capable of exciting
and photo activated from a wide range
of wavelengths from the 365 to the
656 nanometers
micropoint can be used in several
applications
such as a bleaching bleaching and and
caging
and in this video you can see the photo
activation of vesicles
turning from green to red
using the micropoint forward this photo
activation
physical distance track speed
can be determined with immarish
software
so i will wrap up presenting why endor
could deliver all the imaging challenges
faced by dr dr castillo
dr castillo needed a live imaging system
that would be able to deliver images
that could overcome the challenges of
life cell imaging such as phototoxicity
and photobleaching
but could also do so acquiring with a
very high temporal
resolution the dragonfly delivers
images with very low phototoxicity and
photobleaching
due to the combination of the dual
microlens system that is
highly efficient in capturing light and
of andors high sensitive detectors emccd
and decimals detectors meaning that you
can acquire
images with high quality when even using
low very low light exposure
dr castillo used multiple imaging
techniques
confocal turf to analyze
membrane uptake at the cleavage furrow
serve
to image very high dynamic small
details and frap to induce photo
activation
of the regions at the membrane
and this to do all of these imaging
techniques
either you have multiple imaging
equipments or you have a system the only
system
that could deliver all this imaging
modality
in in a single row which is
the dragonfly super resolution
in life cell imagings were also
delivered
due to under self-stream surfstream
gps algorithm that is used
and appropriate for live cell super
resolution
combining the optogenetic devices
with the higher temporal resolution of
the dragonfly
dr castillo was able to induce the
cleavage furrow
with the optogenetics and then to
acquire
immediately after the induction of the
cleavage furrow
and therefore to deliver a solution
for how cytokinesis membrane how
membrane is remodeled
in the pre-cytokinesis opposition
and this is all for now thank you so
much for listening
thank you dr florindo dr castillo and dr
milan
for your informative presentations we
will now start the q a portion of our
webinar
if you have any questions you would like
to ask please do so now just click on
that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have so many
great questions already coming in
let's start with this one dr florendo
the dragonfly is a spinning disc
i had the impression that the spinning
discs are suitable for live imaging
in thin samples but not that good for
thick sample
imaging could you comment on this
so uh thank you so much for this
excellent question
uh traditionally multi-point confocal
systems
spinning disks there was they were not
very good for imaging six samples
due to crosstalk on the pinholes
and in these older systems the crosstalk
would actually begin
in specimens above the 5 over 10 microns
depth but in dragonfly at the 40 and 35
micron spring hole provided
and with under custom pitched pinhole
spacing
results in 10 times more background with
gestation
than traditional spinning disc systems
also when comparing single pinhole
confocals
with point scanner systems with spinning
disk systems
point scanners saw excellent performance
in background
rejection but in practice comparing
with the dragonfly using real samples we
have
delivered surprising results the slow
scanning speed
and high bleeding bleaching rates of the
point scanners
combined with infurian sensitivity
result in surprisingly poor imaging
performance in thicker specimens
we actually have clients who have
abandoned their projects
on six samples that could not be done in
point scanners due to bleaching
or slow speeds and those projects
were actually gained lives again with
the dragonfly
and i must say that we have clients that
were
even image samples within
millimeters of depth in clear tissue
so in our days and with the dragonfly
you can image
samples that are sick as well as simple
that are seen thank you so much
and thank you dr flando dr casillo let's
come over to you for this question
if you activate row a and add a row
inhibitor
will the furrow still form
thank you uh so much uh this is a cutest
question
usually um in this cell that we perform
the experiment
uh the row uh rose cells the macrophages
they express uh three isoforms of
raw uh a b and c and
the the most uh
is a form that they express is row a
another thing is that the gap that we
are using to activate row a
is more is specific or
has more affinity for row a
that's the other two isoforms
then i think is one of the things that
we didn't try
and now that it would be curious to see
an interesting to see if one that you
inhibit roy
and you is still recruiting this guess
is i i it would be really interesting to
see if the other two
isoforms can substitute the royal
activity
and that is enough to
induce photo formation or yields those
proteins are not required
for this and it's more like a
specific array that is an interesting
question because it's something that
uh we didn't we didn't try but uh
basically we didn't try because we were
um
sure that the we are sure that the
gap that we are using is more specific
for
roy
thank you dr castillo dr florendo let's
come back over to you
and this is a few parts here from the
photo manipulation tools presented
i would like to ask one can they be
combined with the dragonfly and two
what are the main differences between
mosaic
and micropoint
so as just presented by dr castillo talk
the photo manipulation tools presented
can in fact
be combined with a dragonfly
and i will now pass to the second part
of the talk
the sorry the question uh if if
which manipulation tools under offers
so emer offers the mosaic and micro
point
and the main differences between the
mosaic and micro point are
that micro point allows single point
illumination
and you can use it for higher laser
power applications
such as ablation and dna damage
well whereas mozaic is a device more
suitable for optogenetics
is extremely fast and allows
simultaneous multi-point illumination
of complex regions thank you so much for
your question
and thank you dr castillo another one
for you
this one has two parts have you measured
membrane traffic across the mid body
and if not could you comment on what you
think is happening in the mid-body
preamp vision
one of the one of the things that we
did in in this work and
like uh we
we studied the trafficking in the
intercellular
bridge we didn't quantify
uh we just uh we saw the photos
the photo we photo bleached the
intercellular bridge and
as we can as we saw in the presentation
we could drag some vesicles going
through the intracellular bridge
that let us hypothesize that the
exocytosis is happening there
about the mid body and the final code
one of the things is uh we think that
this process is more complex and
requires another signal
and on the recruitment of other proteins
machinery
that takes for to the final code
to split the cells completely into
independent cells
thank you and thank you dr castillo and
we have time for one more question
dr florendo let's have you answer this
question
what are the super resolution options
offered by the dragonfly
so thank you so much for this question
and
i will now talk about the super
resolution options offered by the
dragonfly
so the dragonfly offers this storm and
first stream
and i will explain a bit more about what
under offer
in each of these super resolution
modalities
in the dragonfly for this storm the
stable laser that is used for confocal
imaging whitefield and turf
can also be applied for this storm and
to achieve the high power laser
requirements for this storm
dragonfly borealis illumination system
is designed with four motorized
illumination
zoom which will increase the power
density
of the incident light up to 36
more times with we can
deliver 3d single molecule data with
this term
by the use of an astigmatist lens that
will create a distorted psf
that varies with the actual defoxes
researchers will
will actually be able to determine the
3d
single molecule localization data of
their molecule of their interest
resolutions up to 30 nanometers are
achievable with this storm
we also provide as very
well presented by dr castillo in the
talk
search stream and first stream is
embedded into wonders cameras and fusion
the dragonfly software and it's a gpu
accelerated algorithm so search stream
uh implementation of dr enriquez surf
algorithm allows you to acquire
images in real time super result
images and due to its low power
requirements
it's compatible with live cell imaging
it can be
combined with any imaging modality
offered by dragonfly
whitefield confocal or turf it is
extremely fast
delivering super resolved images with
speeds up to 10 frames per second
and it can deliver super resolution
images
deep inside the cells and tissues
very importantly as well her stream
images do not require
any specific sample preparation
thank you so much
thank you dr ferendo
now i would like to thank our audience
for their time today and for their
interesting questions
those questions we were unable to answer
live today and those that are submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the email address you provided
at the time of registration i would once
again like to thank
dr claudia florindo dr alan mullen
and dr john castillo for their time
today and for their important research
we'd also like to thank lavroots and our
sponsor andor
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon
have a great day
you